hello and welcome back to the Karen's
cup Yasir we've got a very exciting
round to underway but one of the fun
things about being here at the scene who
is chess club to do commentary is some
of the special events we get to do
especially when we get to work with the
kids and one of my recent trips here I
got a chance to go to Carly middle
school and work with a group of girls
and it was a phenomenal fun experience
working with them and we actually have
from Carlene
Kelly good lochley and she's here to
talk to alejandro well thank you Jen
we're here with Kelly good Lockley from
Carlene yes and you are the head of
girls empowerment magic Jeff tell us a
little bit about your program it's for a
group of six to eighth grade young
ladies and we teach them about life and
how to navigate through different
circumstances we take them on trips
that's why we met you guys you guys came
to visit the school I have about maybe
75 now young ladies and this is our
fourth year in practice so we're here to
just help the young ladies get through
whatever they need to get through and
get them ready for high school
and those why is this an important
initiative how is it born
well we're title in school so we deal
with the low income maybe
disenfranchised neighborhood students
and maybe just to fill the gaps of where
they may be lacking in some areas
not that all low-income families like
the founder fundamentals or you know the
foundational elements but some do and so
we're here to fill those gaps and they
send them on different experiences so
they know they have choices now last
December the st. Louis Chess Club
partnered up with you guys not tell us a
little bit about that event well it
started off as a Jim and Jim initiative
with our seventy-five students but then
it it morphed into the whole female
student body of two hundred and seventy
girls that's a lot of people it was and
it we went
the whole building we breakout sessions
with Wash U the Chess Club virtues of a
queen and they're still raving about it
now so they love the experience it
sounds absolutely great
that's a little bit of what you hope to
accomplish with this program in the long
term and perhaps tell us a little bit of
the alums that you have well this is our
fourth year but this is the this is the
third year for our ambassadors okay so
the previous years the previous two
years they were just once a semester but
I thought in order for them to retain
the information we needed some
continuity so now it's a year-round
initiative and it's been that way for
the last two years so I think our
graduating students this year are
graduating eighth graders I would
consider my graduating class because
that would have meant they've been in
sixth seventh in eighth grade and those
are my ambassadors so they work
throughout the building they represent
us everywhere we go and so yeah that
would be my graduating class when they
when they walk across the stage this
year as graduating eighth graders that
would be my graduating class that sounds
absolutely great I'm looking forward I
guess because I've seen the growth from
sixth to eighth grade so it's paying off
must be amazing it is amazing guys are
coming to visit us here in the Karin's
cover yes we are
Wednesday we'll be here that's very
exciting with bells on and the girls
that are coming they are not novice
necessarily suggested so they'll get the
full experience of what you guys have
here this is the best-kept secret in
town I've ridden past this place many
times I'm sure they'll get the full
experience and love it because I'm
impressed already and we're happy to
have you guys I'm sure that they'll have
a great inspiration from some of the
world champions that we have here I'm
sure that they will love playing chess
and see them in participation I like to
see women in power and power other women
so once you've been exposed to different
things you know you have choices so
hopefully they'll take away you know the
world is bigger than
Louis because all of these international
players here and hopefully you know have
lots of fun I'm looking forward to it
myself I really enjoyed getting a chance
to meet some of your girls in December
and can you tell me what you think chat
specifically fits in in your program is
there anything you notice about them
playing chess that might be the most
effective way for them to get certain
life skills well cheston's is a thinking
person's game and so what we tell them
is to think before you act
so in chess is you have to think moves
ahead and it has a consequence so in
chess you may just lose the match but in
life the consequence could be bigger so
I need you to think ahead of your
emotions and make the right choice so I
see that hey think about it slow down
and I see that happening especially in
our ambassadors from when they were six
to eighth grade so I'm loving we can all
take a wonderful program and I can't
wait to see everybody on Wednesday will
be here with our t-shirts all right
thank you
thank you Kelly and your leadership it
for everything you do for the community
that's marvelous I will look forward to
receiving your class of girls that's
right they're gonna take a tour of the
museum as well the World Chess Hall of
Fame's just across the street it's
really exciting to me actually when I
visited them they they actually created
art themselves so some of them didn't
play chess at all there was the entire
student body so a couple hundred many of
them day many of them did but some
didn't so we ended up doing this kind of
a kind of art project where they created
test squares and they use both
empowering and critical things that
people had said to them you know kind of
trying to show that you should be very
mindful of the encouraging words and as
for the critical words try to flesh it
out
very nice and there we see some of the
photos you're doing a lecture do you
remember what you lectured on oh yeah
don't actually about the test Queen and
about how she's the most powerful piece
and that's like a symbol for the world
where women are of course the most
powerful no argument from these also
this chest cops program that dovetailed
with that day as we also had female cops
come in and talk to the girls and that
was the idea that it with cops and
children kind of connecting on the chess
board they can see themselves in a
different way that relationship and
that's something that the Chess Club is
continuing to build so we see here this
this one that woman was just incredible
she was really inspiring to the kids and
of course not the vebber haami I was
there as well Sarah Sarah Chun who was a
chess master you might remember her from
back and the US Championships days she
also came out to inspire the Kaman and
now she's Sarah is going to wash it wash
ooh right Washington University yeah
exactly yeah okay fantastic
you